auf der diesjährigen e3 in los angeles
wurden wieder eine menge spannende
spiele vorgestellt
doch das thema auf dass fast jeder immer
wieder zu sprechen kam war virtual
reality okay das stellte nun endlich die
finale version ihres headsets vor und
microsoft demonstrierte eindrucksvoll
die minecraft mit der hohlen brille
aussehen könnte
was ist heute schon mit virtueller
realität möglich und was bleibt noch
science-fiction
die antwort gibt es jetzt bei what
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge muss die möglichkeit in andere
welten einzutauchen und dabei die reale
welt zu vergessen wurde uns schon einmal
versprochen doch anfang der 90er war die
consumer technik noch nicht bereit
schlechte screens und eine zu starke
verzögerung verursachten kopfschmerzen
doch seit die option trifft auf
kickstarter mit beinahe 25 millionen us
dollar unterstützt wurde ist die
technikbranche im virtual reality fieber
htc sony microsoft oder samsung fast
jede größere technik firma hat ihren
versuch gestartet die virtuelle welt zu
erobern
aber wovon reden wir ja eigentlich
zuerst einmal sollte man zwischen zwei
dingen unterscheiden
virtual reality und augmented reality
bei letzterem augmented reality sieht
man die welt durch eine glasscheibe wenn
das gerät ausgeschaltet ist kann man
normal sehen aber eingeschaltet fügt das
gerät digitale objekte zu deiner
normalen sicht hin zu von navigations
feilen über fotos bis hin zur richtigen
bildschirm kann das fast alles seien
gute beispiele hierfür sind googles glas
oder microsofts neues hoya lens der
große hype um google glas ist inzwischen
vollkommen abgeklungen und man wird
wider erwarten nicht ständig von
brillenträgern gefilmt wahrscheinlich
hat google testen wollen wie gut wie
glas bei den leuten ankommt und ob die
gesellschaft quasi schon bereit für die
technik ist und ich wette dass eines der
vielen projekte bei google ex immer noch
mit einer virtual reality brille
beschäftigt ist und wir in den nächsten
jahren bei google
den zweiten versuch sehen werden doch
dafür ist jetzt microsofts halo lenz der
große trend
die demo hat bereits viel versprochen
ein computer der immer bei mir ist wenn
ich ihn brauche fenster die mir folgen
und die ich überall hingehen kann so
dass meine umwelt quasi zu meinem
desktop wird wie in iron man doch auch
hoya lens hat seine probleme primär das
kleine sichtfeld in dem die grafiken
angezeigt werden können
von den 360 grad reality kann hier nicht
die rede sein
trotzdem glaube ich dass gerade
augmented reality eine sehr große
zukunft hat
mit ihr kann ich besser kommunizieren
wichtige sachen im blick behalten und
verlieren trotzdem nicht die richtige
welt aus den augen
augmented reality fügt unserer welt
features hinzu ohne sie komplett zu
ersetzen
im gegensatz dazu schaut man bei virtual
reality auf einen computer screen alles
was man sieht wird vorher durch einen
computer chip berechnet das ist zum
einen natürlich rechten aufwendiger
bietet aber viel mehr potenzial für eine
komplette version entstanden ist virtual
reality beim militär
dort wird es für simulationen verwendet
die man in der echten welt nicht
durchführen sollte zum beispiel das
testen von buch landungen in einem
kampfjet auch soldaten trainieren mit
bio headsets immer häufiger knifflige
gefahrensituationen und spätestens da
werden natürlich die zocker unter uns
hellhörig
doch bis wir wie in gamer komplett in
eine welt eintauchen können wird es wohl
noch ein wenig dauern
viele der simulationen die es jetzt
schon für vr headset zu testen gibt sind
eben genau das simulation was das jetzt
fehlt sind die richtigen spiele die
extra für das spielen mit v headsets
designt wurden die interessantesten
spiele im moment sind starr citizen und
iva eine adaption von eve online
solche flugsimulationen wie hier sind
prädestiniert für vr gaming weil die
virtuelle realität sitzend in einem
cockpit relativ nah an die wirklichkeit
heran kommt nämlich sitzend auf der
couch
die größten spieler auf dem virtual
reality markt sind im moment oculus rift
sonys morpheus und das erst kürzlich
vorgestellte weiß von htc und steam
hersteller war zumindest die ersten
beiden konnte ich bereits austesten und
ich muss sagen es ist definitiv ein
komplett anderes gefühl
sobald man seinen kopf bewegt fühlt man
sich viel tiefer eine spielwelt hinein
gezogen als es jemals mit einem monitor
möglich gewesen wäre
aber es gibt auch probleme dadurch dass
die screens zum beispiel so nah direkt
vor dem auge sitzen kann man beinahe
jeden einzelnen pixel erkennen und die
virtuelle realität findet relativ
schnell ihre grenzen
sobald man zum beispiel nach irgendetwas
greifen möchte und sein körper auf
normale art und weise einsetzen möchte
trotzdem sind wir meiner meinung nach
auf dem richtigen weg und ich glaube
gerne dass sie die dritte oder vierte
generation dieser via headset einen
richtig in ein spiel hineinversetzen
kann
also wer weiß schon ob es bald
vielleicht total normal sein wird mitten
im park minecraft zu spielen
ich glaube wird schon reality wird nicht
nur die welt der zocker nachhaltig
verändern sondern auch neue
möglichkeiten der kommunikation schaffen
so wie hier in der new york university
wo die grenzen von virtueller realität
ausgetestet werden
dabei können zum beispiel menschen mit
hilfe von dreidimensionalen zeichnungen
viel besser verdeutlichen was sie
kommunizieren möchten
genauso gibt zur zeit der ersten
mobiltelefone eigentlich noch keiner
erahnen konnte zu was macht uns
heutzutage in der lage sind so kann auch
heute noch keiner erahnen was wir mit
unserem leben in der zukunft einstellen
wird
viele experten sind heutzutage der
meinung dass virtual reality ein eigenes
medium ist genauso wie fernsehen oder
das internet
und wenn man sich mal vorstellen welchen
einfluss diese neuen medien auf unser
leben hatten
dann fällt es schwer virtual reality
nicht spannend zu finden was man ihr
welche möglichkeiten bietet virtual
reality noch in der zukunft schreibt mir
auf jeden fall unten in die kommentare
ansonsten geht ein riesengroßes
dankeschön unmik und kanal für sie kelly
shaken für die ganzen geilen animationen
hier in diesem video den kanal von
physikern schenken gibt es da mit ganz
vielen coolen animations- videos und ein
riesengroßes dankeschön geht auch an den
professor kennt perlend von der new york
university für das bereitstellen von
vielen der videos hier in dem video und
für einen sehr geil vortrag hier in köln
ansonsten vielleicht bist du schon und
bis zum nächsten mal